[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Travis
starts us off this hour in Toledo hi
Travis welcome to the Ramsey
show all thank you for taking my call
sure what's
up uh I have a negative balance every
month and I'm kind of trying to figure
out how to how to get positive again um
starting off kind of a little rough
every single month after bills and
everything so your your bank account is
negative every month like you're
overdrawn yep I'm overdrawn actually
almost on a weekly
basis um you know I it's funny that you
talk about this I literally just got off
a webinar about this this very thing and
at the end of the day it's probably
boiling down to budgeting issues do you
have a
budget um I've been working on trying to
do one I recently got the every dollar
app uh
premium uh because it was able to track
my stuff better but yeah I'm struggling
like weekly with groceries it's it's
just with a family of five it's hard to
keep it under a certain amount okay so I
want you to not try to do the budget I
want you to actually do it I want you to
go in there put the numbers in there
that's step one you and your wife yeah
have you start have you actually filled
out a budget for the
month uh no I have not I haven't been
able to figure it out okay so that's
step one matter of fact um I want you to
go to Every doll.com budget when this
call is over and I want you to sign up
for the next webinar because if the
issue is I've got it is it you know is
it I'm not I don't have time to do it or
I'm not prioritizing the time to do it I
really want you to prioritize this the
time sit down with your wife tonight
start looking at it what's your take
home pay uh take-home is about 3600 a
month how much is your
rent uh the mortgage is 560 a month
what's your car payment uh car payment
is a little high it's 4 41 a month
mhm okay and five
kids uh three kids wife that is unable
to work due to yes five people three
that is unable to work due to medical
issues what kind of medical issues uh
it's actually like a hereditary
degenerative uh disease where it's
actually just getting worse as time goes
on too
so okay how old are your
kiddos uh I got triplets uh 4 and a half
years old
wow okay so consumer debts kind of got
me you know how
much um not including the car it's about
26,000 okay here's the thing we got to
start at the other end groceries don't
catch the slack groceries are the
thing so we're going to start with this
3600 at the top of the page you follow
me yes minus the important things first
first the most important thing in your
entire budget is
food you have the money to buy food you
may not have the money to do some other
stuff but you have the money to buy food
period end of story okay so 3600 minus
food what are you'all spending on
food uh I try to keep it around 180
bucks a week but I mean it's usually 180
bucks to 220 how often do you eat out
how often do you eat
out um maybe once a week but it's just
me for lunch when I'm unable to pack I
am going to a trade school at night it's
either lunch or dinner I go three nights
a week um okay all right so so if we
take um 800 bucks 700 bucks for your
budget for food right for a month for a
month that leaves us
$2,900 so you can buy food food's first
you got me yes I don't care if you pay
anybody else until you feed your family
you follow me all right second thing is
we pay $550 for shelter
done right yep and then we pay the light
bill and the water bill so we're warm
we're fed and we're
dry okay this is survival first you
following me yes uh we may not keep this
stupid car because it's freaking out of
control if we can't come up with a way
to get it paid off soon it's got to go
but for now we're going to pay the car
payment too food shelter clothing
transportation and utilities are basic
necessities of life we call those the
four walls you do the four walls before
you do anything else everyone else and
let me tell you who's at the bottom of
the freaking list student loan how big's
a student loan I don't have one thank
you know who's right at the bottom next
to them stupid credit card companies
because you know what they can do if you
don't pay them nothing except destroy
your credit and sue you eventually eight
years from now but we're going to take
care of them before we get there okay
they're at the bottom of the page so let
me just tell you your emotional state
and your sense of control over your
destiny changes when your family is fed
the lights and water are paid and the
mortgage is paid and you you are in a
different place emotionally and
spiritually the rest of it is just a
stupid game I'm behind
on okay but right now it feels like life
or death because you've got groceries as
the last thing not the first thing
yes by the time I pay groceries I'm
overdraft no by the time you pay
MasterCard Oh wait we're not going to go
to overdrift so we're not paying
MasterCard screw them okay for this
month and then we've got to adjust our
income now you got to get your income up
dude what are you gonna do to get your
income up it it it goes up progressively
every uh every six months as long as I
keep up my uh my apprenticeship and
everything so well you you got you got
six months Ah hell then ahead of you
what are we goingon to do in the short
term to get it up
um you're going to stade school three
nights a week what are we doing on those
other nights because you're about to do
some more work dude your family's hungry
homework and doing whatever I can yeah
around the house housework and
everything yeah you're going to probably
not be doing as much of that the laundry
May pile up a little bit because you got
to go make some money cuz 3600 bucks is
tough
M so the way you the way you get this
straight Side Up is you first take care
of necessities and then two you get over
the top of it and we're going to cut
expenses and add income and that creates
margin and that will get you under
control Travis so you you do have a very
tight tight tough
situation so something's got to go out
of the expense lines and something's got
to come up quickly in the income side
because you know you know it's not easy
you got a really nice low house payment
it's the best thing in this whole story
right
now so you got you gotta fixable
situation but the faster you get the
income up and the out go down the faster
the Pain's going to leave okay does that
make sense to you yeah absolutely I was
just nervous about missing credit card
payments and stuff I want to give you
permission to feed your children before
you pay MasterCard yeah I understand
okay when you get that straight in your
head all of a sudden it changes
everything CU if everybody's fed and the
lights are done and the water's paid and
and the house payments paid I mean we
live to fight another day but if we pay
MasterCard and then we don't have enough
money to feed the triplets dad gum
that's not fun been there done that that
terrorizes your butt doesn't it yes it
does been there done that